This is Arya Stark in Game of Thrones season
one, in season three, in season five. What
happened? And what’ll happen next? Let’s
work it out. Arya is the daughter of Ned Stark
and Catelyn Tully. At the start of the series
she’s a scrawny little nine-year old girl,
and a bit of a “wild” child, “fierce”
and “willful”. While her older sister
Sansa plays the part of a lady, dressing nicely,
speaking politely, learning to sew and sing,
Arya likes to fight and ride and explore. She doesn’t “want to be” “the highborn
lady [she’s] supposed to be”, so she
“never seem[s] to fit” – a bit like
Jon Snow, who she has a “close” relationship
with. Jon gives Arya her little sword, Needle,
before going away to the Wall. Arya also “love[s]”
her direwolf, Nymeria, but has to send her
away after an incident with Joffrey, which
also leads to the death of Sansa’s direwolf,
under the orders of Queen Cersei, and the
death of Arya’s friend Mycah, at the hands
of the Hound, filling Arya with guilt and
grief, anger and hate. At King’s Landing,
Syrio Forel teaches Arya to fight, and to
be strong, perceptive, agile, quick and fearless.
So Arya trains, chases cats, overhears a
very interesting chat, and eventually everything
starts going wrong again. King Robert dies, Lannisters kill Starks, and Syrio seemingly
sacrifices himself to save Arya. Arya kills
a boy on the way out of the Red Keep, then
lives rough in King’s Landing until she
witnesses the death of Ned Stark. So in the
first book and season of Game of Thrones,
Arya’s friend, her teacher, and her father
are all killed. She’s separated from her
family, her direwolf and her life as a highborn.
All her grief becomes hatred for the people
who caused these things, she wants them dead,
but is powerless to do anything against
them. For now.
Arya tries to return to the north with a group
of Night’s Watch recruits. She assumes
the identity of a boy named Arry, and makes
friends with Gendry, Hot Pie and Lommy. But
the group is attacked by Amory Lorch, forcing
Arya and her friends to fight and flee – on
the way Arya frees the mysterious Jaqen H’ghar.
Arya and co. are captured by Gregor Clegane,
Lommy is killed, and they’re taken to Harrenhal. Arya sees horrible things at Harrenhal.
Murder, torture, rape. She’s meets many
of the worst people in Westeros – Amory
Lorch, Gregor Clegane, the Brave Companions,
Tywin Lannister, Roose Bolton. Arya starts
to lose touch with her identity. Induction
to Harrenhal is like joining the military
or a cult. She’s stripped and scrubbed and
has her hair cut, has the “pride” and
“defiance” beaten out of her, and is worked
hard. To survive in Harrenhal, she can’t
be “wild Arya”, or “fierce” Arry.
She becomes a “grey mouse girl”, called
Weasel , “ke[eping] to the crannies and
crevices … of the castle”. When Roose
Bolton takes Harrenhal, she takes the name
Nymeria, or Nan, and thinks she’s “not
even [herself any more]”. One of the few
things connecting her to her to her identity
as Arya is her hatred for the people she wants
dead. She thinks about them as she works,
lists them in her “prayer” before sleep, constantly broods on killing and hate. Jaqen
H’ghar turns up and tells Arya that since
she saved him and his companions, he owes
a sort of death debt, so he kills people for
her. This “ma[kes Arya] brave again”,
“a ghost instead of a mouse”. When Jaqen
leaves, he gives her a coin, and the words
“Valar morghulis” – all men must die. Arya escapes Harrenhal with Hot Pie and
Gendry, killing a guard on the way out. So
in this book, Arya moves closer to violence
and hate, and begins to separate from her
identity.
At start of Book and Season 3, Arya is free
from the horrors of Harrenhal. She rides
for Riverrun, to find Robb and Catelyn, but
she’s captured by the Brotherhood Without
Banners, an outlaw group ostensibly fighting
to “defend the realm”. She sees the trial
of the Hound and the resurrection of Beric
Dondarrion, and though the Brotherhood promise
to take Arya to her mother, that never ends
up happening. Hot Pie starts work at an inn,
and Gendry joins the Brotherhood, leaving
Arya feeling abandoned and betrayed. She
wants people she can trust, a family, what
she calls a “pack”, and she doesn’t
find it with the Brotherhood, so she runs
away, and is caught by the Hound, Sandor Clegane.
The Hound takes her across the riverlands,
trying and failing to ransom her off. They
kill Freys and Lannisters together, and develop
this wonderful complicated friendship. Arya
hates the Hound for killing Mycah, and goes
on and on about how she’s gonna kill him,
or run away, but she never does, even though she gets lots of opportunities.
The Hound says he only keeps Arya around
so he can sell her off, but even after that
fails and she’s not worth anything to him
anymore, he stays with her. Why? Arya and
the Hound are very very similar. They’ve
both suffered, both been forced to serve terrible
men doing terrible things, both feel betrayed
by their siblings. They’re both cynical
and angry and “hateful”. They hate Joffrey,
they hate Cersei, they hate Gregor, they
hate cowards, they hate liars. They both
use literal disguises that hide their faces
– and they use symbolic disguises in that
they both act tough, threatening people, boasting
about killing, acting like they need no one, and killing makes them happy, when in
truth, they are afraid, they feel pain, they
cry. They have no families to speak of, no
homes, nowhere to go. They say they don’t
care about each other, but clearly they do.
They have no one else. So when Arya refuses
to give Sandor the gift of mercy, maybe that
was spite for killing Mycah. But maybe, Arya
couldn’t bring herself to kill her only
friend. Anyway. With no one and no reason
left to stay in Westeros, Arya sails to Braavos,
clinging to the last thing she has left – her
will to kill the people in her prayer.
In Braavos, Arya uses Jaqen’s coin to join
the Faceless Men, a cult of assassins who
worship death. To truly become a Faceless
Man, Arya must let go of her identity, of
her “hopes and dreams, [her] loves and hates
… [of] all that makes [her] who [she is]”.
Arya must become “No one”. Arya works
sweeping floors, and cleaning corpses. Under
the name of Cat she spends time in the city,
learning the language, and the Faceless Men
teach her to lie. She’s later made blind,
and given the name Beth, in the books not
so much as a punishment as part of her training,
to develop all her senses. After her sight
is restored she’s taken to the Hall of Faces,
which the Faceless Men use to assume false
identities. Arya becomes “The Ugly Little
Girl” and Mercy. Arya is ordered to kill
an insurance man, which she does, in the books,
but she also kills some targets of her own.
She kills Dareon, a Night’s Watchman who’s
breaking his vows, and kills Raff the Sweetling,
one of Gregor Clegane’s men, from her list.
In the show it’s Meryn Trant instead, but
the kill is similar. So that’s Arya’s
story so far. In these first five books and
seasons, she’s gone from a sweet kid to
a vicious assassin. She’s lost everything.
Her family, her friends, and her sense of
self. What will happen next? Where can she go from here?
She’ll obviously probably be doing some
killing, and the people on her list are the
obvious targets. But they’re all down south,
involved in other stuff. Where Arya really
wants to go is north, to the Wall, to Jon. Arya and Jon think of each other all the
time. Arya only goes to Braavos cause
the ship can’t take her to Jon, and much
of Jon’s story in Dance is about Arya – the
plot with Mance, the decision to ride south.
Of course, Jon is stabbed pretty bad, but
there’s strong evidence he’ll be resurrected
by Melisandre – who in the show, meets Arya
and tells her they’ll meet again. Anyway
maybe the Faceless Men, as worshippers of
death, disapprove of Jon’s resurrection,
and send Arya to have him killed a second
time. Maybe Arya will wear the face of Jeyne
Poole, who, in the books, is used by the Boltons
as a fake Arya to marry Ramsay, so Arya may
impersonate the person who impersonated her.
It’s implied that Faceless Men aren’t
allowed to kill people whose names they know, though, so Arya might only be sent to kill
Jon if Snow goes by Azor Ahai or King Jonathon
Starkgaryen the First or whatever. But the
point – is – imagine the drama of Arya
being sent to kill Jon. It could be the big
test of whether Arya truly is no one – could
she bring herself to kill her beloved brother,
the last of her family that she knows of?
Could she truly let go of her identity as
Arya? The answer is probably no. The kindly
man says “[he doesn’t] think [Arya] can”
become no one, that beneath all her names,
all her identities, there’s still some Arya
there, and it looks like he’s right, Arya
says as much herself. She doesn’t kill
for the Many-Faced God, she kills to avenge
her friends and family. And she keeps Needle.
“Try as she might … she [cannot] rid herself
of Arya”, can’t become no one.
So will she go back to being Arya? What’s
left to go back to? Arya’s “home [is]
gone, her parents dead, and all her brothers
slain but Jon”, plus tree-boy Bran and
unicorn-island Rickon. And what’s even left
of Arya? She’s been Horseface, Underfoot,
Arry, Lumpyhead, Lumpyface, Weasel, Nan,
Squab, Salty, Cat, Blind Beth, “The Ugly
Little Girl”, Mercy… and each one has
worn away at her identity. Like “the kindly
man” says, there is an Arya beneath all
this, but this Arya is so… broken. She says
she has a “hole inside her where her heart
had been”, that “The hole will never feel
any better”. Arya is extremely tough and
adaptable, but she’s an eleven-year-old
girl. Her family and friends have been butchered
before her, she’s seen murder and worse
at Harrenhal, her best friend is “the worst
shit in the Seven Kingdoms”, and she joins
a literal death cult. She’s deeply traumatised,
part of why she tries to forget her life as
Arya is to dissociate from her suffering. After
all she’s been through, Arya can hardly
function like a person, let alone become
the noble lady she never wanted to be in the
first place. She can’t trust, she can’t
relax, all she knows is killing and survival.
She can’t return to a normal life as Arya
Stark. But she can’t truly be “no one”,
either. Who or what can she be?
Arya is connected to the old gods, the “nameless,
faceless gods of the greenwood”. She feels
them guiding her steps, and when she prays
to them in Clash, she hears a response. She
hears her father’s voice repeating
“When the snows fall and the white winds
blow, the lone wolf dies, but the pack survives”,
she is reminded that she has “The wolf blood”,
and she hears a “great pack” of wolves,
“calling to [her]”. Arya is closely associated
with wolves throughout the series. People
call her a “wolf girl” and a “wolf bitch”. She sees wolves, she hears wolves, she
howls to wolves and they howl back. She thinks
of herself as a wolf. In fact, Arya is a
warg, someone who enters the minds of animals, like Bran enters Summer. She wargs a couple
of cats in Braavos, but mostly wargs her
direwolf, Nymeria. She has wolf dreams, meaning
while she sleeps, her mind becomes one with
Nymeria, who now leads a “great pack [of]
hundreds of … mankill[ing wolves]” around
the riverlands. Arya wolf dreams all
the time, more and more as the series goes
on, and this forms a new identity, different
to Arya and different to “no one” – she
calls herself the “night wolf”. And this
is what she wants. Arya wishes and prays
to be made into a wolf. And there actually
is a way that could happen.
We know from the prologue of Dance that when
a warg, like Arya, dies, they may live a second
life by having their spirit leave their body
and become one with their animal. If Arya
dies, her spirit could become one with Nymeria.
There’s plenty of foreshadowing that Arya
may die. Ned compares Arya to her aunt Lyanna,
who had “The wolf blood”, was “willful,
and dead before her time”. Jon jokes that
after winter, “they will find [Arya’s]
body with a needle still locked tight between
[her] frozen fingers”. And we’ve heard
over and over from Arya and others that “valar
morghulis” – all men must die. George
R. R. Martin has said that the ending of his
series will be bittersweet. The death of
Arya would be tragic, but it’d be sweet
in that Arya would finally have what she’s
wanted all this time. Cause in one sense, Arya’s
story is about a killer’s quest to take
revenge on evil men, but it’s also the story
of a kid trying to find a family, what Arya
calls a pack. This is what Arya’s been
chasing all this time, it’s why she sticks
with Hot Pie and Gendy even when she’d be
safer alone, why she stays with the Hound,
when he murdered her friend, maybe even
why she joins the Faceless Men. There’s
no denying that Arya is a killer, but she
also wants a pack, at least as much as she
wants blood, and becoming Nymeria could give
her both. She’d be “swift and strong,
running down her prey with her pack at her
heels”. Arya dying and becoming Nymeria
would fulfil Ned’s words of “the lone
wolf [dying], but the pack [surviving]”,
it would solve Arya’s identity crisis by
becoming the “night wolf” rather than
Arya or “no one”, and it would give a
beautiful bittersweet ending to a story of
loss of identity and death. A working title
for the final instalment of the series was
A Time for Wolves. You can almost see the
epilogue, the closing moment of the series,
after all the misery maybe we’ll see Arya,
as a direwolf, running with her pack across
the snow.
So feel free to comment what you think will
happen to Arya, and subscribe to Alt Shift
X for more videos on Game of Thrones and more.
Thanks.